[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce numéro spécial du 7 8
et co consacrée à la relance de
l'économie dans les yvelines
après huit semaines de confinement de
nombreuses entreprises ont repris leurs
activités des secteurs comme le commerce
ou le service à la personne de nombreux
secteurs ont connu aussi une chute de
leur chiffre d'affaires durant cette
période
nous ferons le bilan dans le département
nous parlerons aussi des aides accordées
pendant la crise et de l'accompagnement
pour relancer l'économie avant de
revenir sur des initiatives lancées par
des entreprises pour lutter contre le
colis 19 deuxième pôle économique
d'ile-de-france
saint-quentin-en-yvelines attendait avec
impatience la reprise de l'activité avec
près de 16000 entreprises pour 145 mille
emplois dans plusieurs secteurs la
relance économique sera très importante
pour ce tissus pour en parler nous
sommes avec anne failli bonjour jean
nicolas vous êtes directrice générale au
développement économique à saint quentin
en yvelines quelques jours après le
déconfinement quel bilan faites vous des
huit semaines de confinement et quel
impact économique sur le territoire
nous avons lancé une série d'échangés
évidemment avec les tpe les pme de notre
territoire nos grands comptes
également vous savez que saint quentin
en yvelines est un tissu économique
dense riche dans différents secteurs
d'activité il faut pouvoir analyser la
situation secteur d'activité par secteur
d'activité globalement et c'est le cas
plus généralement dans les yvelines on a
évidemment une économie résidentielle je
pense à nos commerces à nos restaurants
acquis et économique est fortement
impacté par par le par la crise et que
nous avons accompagné tout au long
de cette période et que nous continuons
à l'accompagner dans la reprise
donc nos efforts sont particulièrement
centré sur cette filière commerce mais
aussi hôtellerie tourisme loisirs de
façon plus globale de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
singulièrement impact est un parent pas
cette crise parce que nous avons trois
secteurs qui sont au coeur de l'économie
de notre territoire
je pense évidemment à l'automobile je
pense à la filière aéronautique
je pense aussi à la filière btp et donc
nous sommes en lien avec l'ensemble de
nos grands comptes mais aussi toute la
filière la filière ingénierie des
bureaux d'études les pme qui travaillent
avec ces secteurs pour travailler
ensemble sur des solutions qui nous
permettront de rester très en pointe sur
ces différents segments mais met
clairement le tissu économique est
particulièrement impacté sur sur ces
trois secteurs
vous avez parlé des commerçants vous
avez mis en place plusieurs dispositifs
pour accompagner notamment les
commerçants mais aussi les autres
entreprises de certaines filières dont
vous avez mentionné
oui dès la première semaine nous avons
souhaité être auprès autour des de nos
différents chefs d'entreprise je pense
évidemment aux commerçants aux artisans
mais aussi aux pme/pmi de façon elle est
guidée à les orienter dans les
différents dispositifs et mesures
d'appui qui était mis en place au plan
national ou au plan régional nous étions
évidemment en lien avec les cellules
d'écouté d'orientation de la région et
de la chambre de commerce est notre
objectif
dans un contexte où ces mesures ont
parfois beaucoup évolué je pense au
fonds de solidarité les critères ont
beaucoup changé dans les premiers terre
en première semaine c'était d'avoir
l'information la plus précise et la plus
pertinente pour pour nos entreprises
donc un premier élément qui était
essentiellement d'être une cellule
d'information d'orientation
le deuxième point pour nous ça a été de
rendre visible
les deux commerçants et de leur
permettre de faire face à cette crise
majeure qu'il traverse et on en a nous
avons travaillé essentiellement sur la
visibilité de leurs de leurs actions
donc on a mis en place trois outils une
carte interactive qui est toujours
évidemment en ligne et qui permet aux
commerçants de se référencer d'indiquer
des services qui peuvent être déployées
à destination de leur clientèle
un groupe facebook où on a presque eu
maintenant 4000 abonnés pour communiquer
pour continuer à travailler le lien avec
avec les clients et puis un guide de
façon aussi alors apporter des solutions
à la fois dans les mesures comme je
disais tout à l'heure mais aussi dans
l'adaptation de leurs services face à la
reprise et à la nécessité de suivre un
certain nombre de recommandations et de
et de protocoles pour permettre
d'accueillir au mieux de leur clientèle
le déconfinement progressif a commencé
le 11 mai leur maintenant est à la
relance à la reprise de l'activité
comment saint quentin en yvelines
accompagne ce mouvement
on peut penser notamment à travers les
transports les compétences klicki que
dont vous avez la charge les transports
le développement économique comment vous
accompagner ce mouvement dans les
entreprises saint-quentinoise notre
sujet c'est d'accompagner cette emphase
et des entreprises en se dans ce
challenge parce qu'il s'agit pour elle à
la fois d'adapter leurs locaux de mettre
en place l'ensemble des mesures de
protection individuelle des salariés
mais aussi de répondre à leurs craintes
et de susciter et l'envi il ya des
enjeux de management extrêmement
important évidemment dans cette période
notre sujet au sein de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est à la fois de faire passer
des messages clés auprès des entreprises
vous savez que toutes les autorités
appellent nous en particulier nos grands
comptes à suivre de façon majoritaire a
continué le télétravail qui est
d'ailleurs très très largement répandu
sur notre tissu économique
et puis d'accompagner évidemment les
questions de transport en définissant
des plages des plages horaires
qu'il soit le plus large possible pour
l'instant les premiers éléments sont
évidemment que le retour sur saint
quentin en épinette un retour très
progressif large recours encore au
télétravail donc les éléments sont
plutôt là positif sur ces premiers jours
et puis nous allons évidemment mettre
aussi en parallèle en place toutes les
mesures de mobilité douce par rapport à
la relance économique qui va avoir une
nécessité pour les entreprises d'avoir
aussi des fonds d aide de l'état de la
région saint quentin en yvelines
pourrait-il l'agglomération
pourrait-elle participer aux aides
directes pour les entreprises le premier
premier point d'un plan de relance est
d'accompagner dès cette semaine aux
entreprises cela partie du plan de
relance on a lancé trois initiatives
la première c'est de les accompagner
avec un guide très pratico pratique
comme on l'avait fait pour les
commerçants comme on l'avait fait sur
les mesures dead les guides très pratico
pratique qui a pour objectif d'aider les
pme pmi à mettre en place l'ensemble des
mesures qui sont liés à cette reprise
c'est à la fois un point sur leurs
obligations légales ce sont aussi des
solutions pour retrouver ces fameuses
équipements de protection individuelle
en particulier dans le tissu économique
puisque nous avons des entreprises qui
ont su s'adapter et proposer des offres
de services ou des produits qui
permettent aux entreprises de préparer
au mieux cette retour des salariés dans
leur lieu de travail
et puis le troisième point c'est aussi
dingue anisé alors on le fait maintenant
complètement au travers de webinars nous
accompagnons des entreprises en les
mettant en relation avec d'autres pme
grands groupes du territoire qu'il
vienne témoigner de
leur expérience dans cet exercice de
reprise de travail et on a un engouement
assez important ce matin encore on
parler de la question du recrutement
dans cette période particulière et plus
de 70 partis personnes étaient inscrites
à ce à ce webinar donc un vrai sujet et
qu'on a vu tout au long de cette période
de profils mans aussi un vrai sujet de
solidarité et de volonté d' échanges
entre les entreprises du territoire
mes voisins il nous faut préparer la
prochaine phase qui est le plan de
reprise avec des mesures d' aides qui
vont venir compléter les aides
nationales et régionales
merci à eux failli directrice générale
au développement économique à saint
quentin en yvelines est l'illustration
de cette reprise de l'activité
économique la réouverture du centre
commercial espace saint quentin et
skywest 70 % des commerces ont rouvert
le mercredi 13 mai port du masque
obligatoire distributeurs de gel
hydroalcoolique et signalétique pour
garantir les gestes barrière des mesures
strictes ont été prises par la direction
et les commerçants dans les magasins on
écoute mohamed madounari directeur de
l'espace saint quentin et skywest
interrogé par marie denya piccino très
régulièrement il avait les informations
de manière à pouvoir déjà se projeter
savoir un petit peu ce qui se passait et
puis se positionner dans les dents le
dans tout ce processus global c'est des
réflexions assez intéressante parce
qu'il va falloir je pense y réfléchir
sur le long terme comment arriver à
adapter finalement le shopping et le
commerce à ces nouveaux modes de vie qui
peut être amenée à rester plus longtemps
que ce qu'on ne pense
c'est l'une des reprises d'activité
attendu par les français les coiffeurs
après deux mois de confinement longueur
de cheveux et qui crispe certains
d'entre nous un protocole a été mise en
place pour les nouvelles consignes de
sécurité exemple dans ce salon de
coiffure à maurepas
de nouveaux gestes sanitaires à adopter
et champeaux obligatoire pour les
clients de nouveaux équipements à porter
pour les professionnels dans ce salon de
maurepas la reprise d'activité était
fortement attendu les 4 coiffeur était
sur le pont dès l'ouverture
donc la désinfection en fait été
l'essentiel vraiment l'essentiel donc
les tondeuses et sa voix off
mais la voilà on change de cap pour
cette première heure de reprise la
clientèle est plutôt masculine et le
rasage de près et de rigueur n'en
pouvait plus de ma couple a déjà un peu
long alors que l tu deviens de semaine
du coup c'est un peu important de me
sentir comme avant j'ai ici parce qu'il
te reste donc forcément on trouve pas
forcément partout des gens qui puissent
tressé aussi facilement et et faire les
choses proprement
ça devenait vraiment critique sur les
jeux il y avait vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de temps qui me laisse en
coiffeur duo confinement après deux mois
de confinement ce salon accueille
jusqu'à 40000 euros de perte de chiffre
d'affaires ouvert depuis seulement
octobre 2019 l'établissement a tout de
même pu profiter d'un prêt de l'état
on n'a pas été abandonnée il a prévu
quelques z
on a réussi à faire un pg donc on s'en
sort très bien et on est aussi que
passer par une plate forme donc pour
faire de la bande de bons d'achat ce qui
nous a permis d'avoir un petit peu
trésorerie au fur et à mesure pour
pouvoir payer les différentes charges
qui se présentaient dès la première
semaine on a été agréablement surpris on
a eu plus de 1000 euros
de bons d'achat donc sur la première
semaine mille euros sur un chiffre
d'affaires important peut-être que c'est
rien mais dans sur des situations
franchement c'est vraiment vraiment
qu'on sait pas le salon attend jusqu'à
une vingtaine de clients par jour le
carnet de rendez-vous est quasiment
complet pour la semaine
cette reprise d'activité avec le
déconfinement un bol d'air pour une
partie du tissu économique
yves binois fortement impacté par les
dix semaines de confinement de
nombreuses entreprises ont bénéficié des
aides de l'état
le point avec gérard bacheliers
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines il fait un
bilan provisoire des conséquences de la
crise du colis de 19 sur la situation
économique dans le département
dans notre département l'activité a été
moins touchée que pour le reste de
l'ile-de-france puisqu'on à une baisse
d'activité d'à peu près 60% alors que
pour le reste de l'ile-de-france a été
65%
c'est d'ailleurs le même constat pour le
chômage partiel puisque les demandes de
chômage partiel concerne 45 % des
entreprises dans les yvelines
alors que pour l'île de france cela
concerne 60 2 % des entreprises de plus
au niveau du fonds de solidarité qui a
eu à peu près 30 6 millions d'euros donc
qui ont été demandés pour le fonds de
solidarité ça représente à peu près 1000
352 euros par part entreprises le
dernier point c'est par rapport au
tribunal de commerce
bizarrement il ya très peu de donc de
liquidation tribunal de commerce la
moitié des députations habituel et puis
a bien sûr aussi très peu de
d'immatriculation je pense que le
tribunal de commerce attend à une
influent d'arrivée justement de dossiers
à partir de septembre octobre et je
crois que il a raison je crois qu'il y
aura beaucoup de dossiers qui vont
arriver à partir de cette date
malheureusement chômage partiel report
des cotisations sociales et fiscales ou
encore prêts garantis par l'état le
gouvernement a pris dès le début de la
crise des mesures pour soutenir les
entreprises le fonds de solidarité
destiné aux petites entreprises a aussi
été abondés par la région ile de france
et pour la reprise le conseil régional a
décidé de lancer plusieurs dispositifs
pour aider à la relance de l'économie
francilienne
les détails avec alexandra du blanche
elle est vice présidente en charge du
développement économique pour la région
ile de france
[Musique]
c'est un prêt donc effectivement à taux
zéro entre 10000 et 300000 euros pour
les entreprises jusqu'à 250 salariés
il y à un différé de remboursement de 2
ans et ensuite on a sept ans pour
rembourser rembourser ce prêt avec des
pays on va mettre environ 150 millions
d'euros sur ce dispositif
il n'y a pas de caution non plus
personnelle du dirigeant le but c'est de
pallier les manques de trésorerie les
besoins de trésorerie des entreprises
les besoins d'augmentation de bfr besoin
en fonds de roulement tout ce qui est
investissements immatériels et au
matériel et immatériel et on veut être
le plus réactif possible donc ce prêt
s'il est un fer à 50000 euros
il y aura une décision dans les trois à
cinq jours
[Musique]
ce fonds résilience c'est pour aider les
plus petits effectivement entre 0 et 20
salariés ont le feq tous les territoires
d'île de france c'est à dire chaque
territoire par exemple dans les yvelines
pourra bonifier se font mettre un bonus
pour pouvoir aider les entreprises du
territoire donc donc voila et donc c'est
vrai on est en train de monter ce fonds
de 100 millions d'euros avec tous les
territoires d'île de france les
départements on l'espère la métropole du
grand paris pour arriver à un fonds pour
aider les plus petits les commerçants
nos commerçants nos artisans nos tpe
pour les aider à rebondir
non
c'est pour les effectivement moins de 10
salariés ayant à moins d'un million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et qui ont
connu une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
d'au moins 50% par rapport à l'année
dernière donc il ya eu un volet 1 qui
pouvait aller jusqu'à 1500 euros et un
volet de il faut en parler puisque la
juriste de france ne fait pas encore
assez appelle les entrepreneurs les
commerçants et or c'est un fonds
national
un volet 2 tu peux effectivement aller
jusqu'à 5000 euros pour ceux qui ont
bénéficié de la première la première
vague
c'est un géant de la commercialisation
des espaces publicitaires et de la
gestion du mobilier urbain le groupe jc
decaux implantée à plaisir n'a pas été
épargné par la crise sanitaire du coc
vite 19 diminution brutale de son
activité à partir de mi mars avec un
chiffre d'affaires quasi nul au premier
trimestre le groupe a enregistré une
baisse de 14% de son chiffre d'affaires
des équipes ont assuré un service
d'astreinte jc decaux s'est aussi
mobilisée en permettant un accès gratuit
aux personnels soignants à ses vélos en
libre service avec la reprise le groupe
a relancé ses premières campagnes
publicitaires à partir du 13 mai avec
des règles sanitaires pour ses
collaborateurs
écoutez à ce sujet christophe bertrand
directeur régional de jc decaux
on a quelques annonceurs qui ont
souhaité reprendre la parole très
rapidement ça monte en puissance un sur
les prochaines semaines on s'attend
quand même à ce que cela se passe sur
plusieurs mois pas avant la fin d'année
pour revenir à un niveau qui était celui
d'avoir confinement mais on s'en est en
tout cas on accompagne nos annonceurs et
on essaie d'être inventif là aussi pour
repenser avec eux les modes de
communication dans l'espace public ce
qui est sûr c'est que la ville elle
n'existe pas sans commerçants activités
économiques
il ya pas de vie sans ces acteurs-là la
rue reprend sa place là ça sent on a mis
en place autant de protocole sanitaire
que de métier il ya énormément de métier
dans notre entreprise donc chacun est
formé avec les bons équipements de
protection individuelle avec les bons
gestes pour pouvoir ré intervenir dans
l'espace public réafficher des campagnes
à la flotte municipale des campagnes
commerciales remettre en état aussi des
mobiliers
[Musique]
utilisé dans la recherche scientifique
les supercalculateurs d'atos ont été en
première ligne pour lutter contre le coc
vite 19 des outils technologiques qui
permettent d'accélérer les calculs
informatiques des laboratoires ou des
centres de recherche
ces supercalculateurs sont développées
par des équipes du site d'atos des
clayes-sous-bois saint quentin en
yvelines
on écoute agnès budo senior
vice-présidente responsable des
activités high performance computing
ntoum les grands centres de recherche
nationaux vont mener des études autour
de la simulation numérique qui a à voir
avec différents sujets typiquement des
recherches épidémiologiques pour le
virus était recherche de nouvelles
molécules pour pouvoir ensuite apporté
des vaccins sur le marché et ce genre de
calcul fondamentaux qui permettent en
analyse chimique et biologique
d'apporter des solutions
on fabrique un supercalculateur avec un
réseau d'interpellations rapide et au
lieu de faire un traitement sur une
machine et apc et comme chez vous vous
faites à un traitement numérique en
parallèle sur des milliers de données
c'est ce qui vous permet d'accélérer et
de faire du parallel computing
le groupe explique implantée à montigny
le bretonneux s'est engagé pleinement
dans la crise sanitaire acteurs de
l'innovation spécialisée dans les
services d'ingénierie et de
transformation digitale l'entreprise a
lancé plusieurs projets participation à
une communauté de makers pour la
production en impression 3d utilisation
de l'intelligence artificielle regard
des visières tir porte ou support pour
des écrans de protection en plexiglas
les différentes productions de lino
blague d'explo depuis le début du
confinement
grâce à son imprimante 3d le site de
montigny le bretonneux a participé à un
réseau d'ateliers de fabrication
objectif répondre aux besoins des
personnes en première ligne dans la
région c'est parti d'un mouvement très
large en france à partir de là en fait
on à 108,9 lab
on a une imprimante 3d on a voulu
participer on s'est rapprochés de notre
direction en interne auprès des
collaborateurs qui étaient tous qui
justement sont restées en activité pour
faire ces éléments pourrait d autres
projets l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle pour étudier des mutations
du coc vie de 10,9 dans plusieurs pays à
partir de données publiques
c'est de savoir est-ce qu'on peut par
exemple associer une souche particulière
avec la mortalité qui observait dans les
régions où les pays dans lesquels elle
cj après le second enjeu c'est de
déterminer si le virus a suffisamment
muté pour qu'un vaccin universel ne sera
pas suffisant a donc pour le moment
c'est pas le cas donc c'est plutôt
rassurant répondre à cette crise
sanitaire synonyme d'innovation des
innovations au niveau technologique mais
aussi dans la manière d'innover une
activité entre les collaborateurs du
groupe ouverte vers d'autres partenaires
extérieurs on a appris que l'on pouvait
dépasser des processus y aller vite sur
les choses qui ont du sens on a appris
que individuellement les collaborateurs
avec plein de ressources plein d'idées
plein de propositions et qu'il pouvait
qu on n'était pas les seul tenant du
savoir et que c'est en échangeant étant
beaucoup plus ouvert que finalement les
bonnes idées arrivent comme beaucoup
d'entreprises explique s'est aussi
adaptée au contexte la majorité des
salariés ont poursuivi leur activité en
télétravail spécialiste des machines de
production numérique l'entreprise cadre
des visions implantée à guyancourt a
vendu des imprimantes 3d fournit des
procédés techniques
plusieurs clients comme l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris ou encore
renault objectif répondre aux besoins
face à la crise du colis 19 regarder des
imprimantes 3d pour produire des
visières des pièces pour les
respirateurs ou encore des tirs portes
pour quatre des visions distributeurs de
ces technologies implanté à guyancourt
la crise sanitaire n'a pas été de tout
repos
l'entreprise a notamment fourni 60
machines à l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris
quand on voit à l'échelle de l'ap-hp
c'est les 60 machines qui on était
disposer c'est pas loin de 5000 pièces
qui sortent par semaine en fait les
techniciens de 4 des visions sont aussi
intervenus au technocentre renault de
guyancourt des ajustements techniques
sur des imprimantes 3d déjà présentes
sur le site industriel des machines
utilisées pour la production de visière
et de pièces pour respirateur avec le
fabricant on a fait un travail de fond
pour essayer de trouver une solution à
leur ouvrir on va dire la machine
pendant la durée du coc vide avec une
licence matière qui serait capable
d'être avec ses 7 ces matériaux assez
spécifique au delà des d'hier s'est
démené toute la partie dispositif
respirateur en fait où justement on
avait un besoin de d'avoir une
biocontact biocompatibilité et avoir
justement des matériaux qu'ils puissent
stérilisables la collaboration avec les
groupes industriels du territoire une
activité habituelle pour quatre des
visions dans le contexte de crise
sanitaire les échanges avec les clients
étaient centrées autour du principe de
solidarité
c'est une réorientation stratégique une
adaptation à la crise sanitaire
l'entreprise de les âges implantée à
elancourt à transformer son activité
spécialisée dans l'événementiel a décidé
de lancer la production de mobilier
destiné aux entreprises pour se protéger
du virus
un reportage sur des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude mille présentoirs de
gel hydroalcoolique fabriqué en huit
jours voilà le bilan provisoire de la
nouvelle stratégie de deux les âges
spécialisée dans la fabrication de
mobilier d'événementiel cette entreprise
s'est réinventé des produits destinés à
la préparation du déconfinement pour les
entreprises notamment avec ses écrans de
protection en plexiglas pour les bureaux
sur des grandes plaques dont trois par
deux on peut découper pas mal de pause
avec des systèmes de pied très très
simple à utiliser qui protège vraiment
tous les bureaux toutes les personnes
dans des accueils etc
techniquement il n'y a rien de nouveau
c'est juste des adaptations de forme
pour pouvoir créer en fait des produits
comme vous avez vu tout à l'heure
s'adapter aux besoins dans ce contexte
de crise sanitaire le choix opéré par la
dirigeante de cette société virginie
deneux ville les premiers produits ont
été pensés dès le début du confinement
je me suis vraiment on fait une
réflexion sur les besoins calais à voir
les gens en sortie confinement c'est un
besoin physique et psychologique
physique parce qu'il faut se battre
contre un virus
les psychologique parce que si vous
voulez que les salariés les
collaborateurs soit dans un état serein
pour reprendre leur travail
il faut leur montrer dans l'entreprise
qu'on met tout en oeuvre pour que y ait
zéro risque des cloisons de séparation
entre les bureaux des écrans de
protection pour les restaurants ou les
comptoirs d'accueil plusieurs gammes ont
été conçus avec une cinquantaine de
commandes programmer la production a
redémarré mi avril
chaque gamme va me permettent de
travailler soit aussi bien avec un appel
d'offres public une salle de conférence
à un gros centre de conférences comme on
le fait d'habitude par exemple l ocde où
des clients comme ça ou de senna ucia
que des commerçants ou le restaurateur
du coin avec un tiers du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé au mois de mars cette
nouvelle activité doit permettre
d'amortir cette perte
en attendant une reprise de l'activité
habituelle dans le secteur de
l'événementiel
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis et mission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv 78 à bientôt sur
notre antenne
[Musique]